[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast we
have Christian Sundberg he is a very
special human being that at about the
age of 30 remembered his pre-birth
experience he remembers that he had
chosen to come to Incarnate and the
challenges that he was accepting knew it
would be hard and when he came to
Incarnate he was like no and there was
too much fear and that that life was
terminated he's come to bring to our
awareness just like our vastness and
what we really truly are and our true
nature he's even written a book called A
Walk in the physical and it's available
online for free or you can go buy it on
Amazon or buy the audiobook and I always
recommend people if you have the ability
to buy it buy it because it just sort of
completes the cycle of energy going
forth from him to you to him to all the
things and and it's just so valuable
it's so beautiful it really is like a
message like he said of hope I hope you
enjoy
um Christian's wonderful please hit
subscribe I really really appreciate all
the subscribes it really shows me that
shows on the right track and you like
the kind of interviews that I'm putting
out there if anyone's ever had any any
kind of pre-birth experience or just a
spiritual experience or this information
really resonates with you I just really
I love to read the comments and see what
you guys have to say and um and really
just kind of richen up the rich in the
web of this information it's as he talks
about it's about sort of raising the
temperature so help raise the
temperature
today's pretty intense partner is
athletic greens I take ag1 by athletic
greens literally every day I gave ag1 a
try because I wanted to nourish my gut
health I wanted to have more energy I
wanted to add more micronutrients to my
body I take it first thing in the
morning before I have coffee and then
before I go work out it makes me feel so
good I'm giving my body the nutrition it
craves if a comprehensive solution is
what you need from your supplement
routine then try ag1 and get a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and get
five free ag1 travel packs with your
first purchase go to drink ag1.com
pretty intense that's drink ag1.com
pretty intense check it out how's it
going how are you I'm good nice to meet
you yeah very nice to meet you too I'm
um I'm so fascinated with your story and
your experiences and like there's just
so much in hearing your story that I'm
like yes because I've you know been
fortunate enough and I call it fortunate
to have
sort of out of body experiences
um
whether it's been you know just sitting
on a beach and having some
transcendental experience or whether
it's been through medicine plant
medicine there's just like this there's
a whole nother realm and you're just the
things that you say
are right on right in line with the
experiences I have and I think one of
them that I feel like so many of us can
relate to because we can use the word
dream instead is that when we're in a
dream or in these experiences or having
this pre-birth experience that you did
in this out of this world stuff is that
there's no words for it that is like
right like there's just no way it's like
you wake up from a dream and you you go
okay this isn't going to make a lot of
sense and I how do I even put this like
the feeling doesn't always you can't
even translate it and so like I just
thought that I think that feels like
some of the most resonant sort of
connection to your story that we can all
draw upon that there's just no words
absolutely explain these experiences
yeah there's definitely no language you
know language is local to our world and
our assumptions it's like forms symbols
and our true nature just so fully
transcends that set of forms in this
context so there's just there's just no
way to put language on it I feel like
every time you know we even open our
mouths and try it's like we're just
wrong right away
because it just can't be spoken to yeah
this is a weird out there question right
off the bat but sure be
do you think that we're supposed to get
to a place where we don't really use
words I know this may sound strange
it's all right it's probably going to be
a little bit I'm a pretty I'm a pretty
main you know normal mainstream American
guy you know but I have had these
experiences and I'm I'm passionate about
speaking to these higher contexts as
very real because they are you know this
is this is not a like a religious belief
or mythology or something I mean when
you have these experiences they're even
more real yeah than this than this this
experience and in those contexts many of
those higher systems are thought
responsive so they respond to your
thinking and your intention and in those
systems when we interact with each other
the interaction is very thorough very
complete we use the word telepathy
telepathic you know it's just it's an
exchange of feelings and ideas and it's
just a very full and complete exchange
that's the natural way that we
communicate whereas here on Earth we
have to like put words in a string and
throw them around and yeah
so I think we are moving in that
direction like you said I think as we
continue to awaken and you know evolve
that is the natural
um direction we're moving towards this
is a pretty dense reality system now our
Veil is pretty thick here in general so
it might take some time but that is very
natural for all of us to have that you
know that telepathic interaction
and like just to kind of elaborate more
on it because it's it's it's a space
where it also feels like there's almost
like you come into a knowing right like
there it's not even like there's time
it's not normal communication like on
earth like you say with this whole like
one word after another it's like a rival
of information and you know it was kind
of old to you but you didn't get it told
in the normal linear fashion that you do
here you kind of become aware and it
feels like it's so fast and there's so
many levels of information translated
like it's like the embodiment of it
which is I think when you say that you
they're almost more real
for me it feels like it's so real
because it becomes embodied meaning like
I don't have to reach for the thought I
I never forget and I completely I don't
even need to believe it because I just
know it's true exactly it applies like I
have to effort for it but it's just
there exactly it's there it's complete
and it's at a level of being that
transcends the level where you know
we're here we have to like think about
things and to liberate and decide what
you know is it true how does it apply to
me yeah what you describe is is
excellent it's it's that knowingness in
our being that is so complete and I like
that you use the word embodied you know
because we really do feel it and know it
in the wholeness of our being in a very
tangible way and it's not something that
it's like so personal it's like the most
personal real and complete yeah I I
don't know how to describe it so I think
that was well said oh well it's only
because I've been listening obviously in
the last few days to just so many more
of the of so many Recollections of your
experience that it's so fresh you know
it's just like so fresh that feeling and
I think the feeling is the thing right
and so it's kind of that's the
embodiment is and they say that with
manifestation that you have to put your
body and you you go mentally go there so
that your body then gets the experience
of having whatever it is that you want
so you actually you become it you you
realize it fully and fully embody it and
then you can let it go and kind of let
let the let the universe take care of it
in a way right yeah feeling is an okay
word but it's even deeper it's like a um
a vibration of the being you know it's a
state of being a fullness of being so we
do experience that you know in a very
deep way and then the universe is
listening to that vibration
so then the response back to us is in
accordance with the vibration that's why
you know when people talk about
manifestation they we tend to talk a lot
about thoughts or specific things we're
focused on but really it's that like you
described that that vibration of being
that is communicative and automatically
evokes a response you know because
Consciousness is connected to that which
is and when it vibrates when it intends
when it is a certain way reality
responds naturally that's just how it
works what is the true nature of our
being then according to your experiences
oh well I cannot be described as we said
um we have to turn to metaphors a lot of
these times but we could say that the
true nature of our being is unlimited
joy and freedom and aliveness life
itself with a capital l you know
Consciousness or Spirit those are two
other words it it has so much in it it's
so it's so deep and full of life and joy
and love that there's no there's no word
that we can put on it to describe it we
could say it's the water of the ocean
you know if all that is is the ocean
then the substance of spirit that we are
is the water of the ocean and each each
of us is like a drop of the ocean and
that stuff though that stuff of the
ocean it can't it can't be described
it's just so beyond language totally but
the thing is is that we know we're the
ocean the ocean doesn't know it's the
ocean
right like we can have awareness that we
we are aware we have thoughts we are
aware we're more than this body like we
are we have an awareness to it we're not
the ocean not knowing it's the ocean
that there is level of self-awareness
all throughout the the levels so it's
very difficult to try to speak to the
level of the knowing of ones being at a
given level but
um so I'm not sure if you're talking
about it from this point of view of the
human personality trying to look up and
therefore we have some kind of
cognizance like intellectual cognizance
but at the higher levels even at the
deepest level
the The Knowing of beingness itself
transcends all thought it doesn't need a
definition it doesn't need to be this is
Quantified in some way like we do here
in fact it transcends all that
quantification and gives rise to it it's
deeper than the quantification but it's
very real and self-aware
yeah
love you to elaborate more on that I'm
starting to get a feel for it but I need
you to keep going yeah so at those
deeper levels they transcend form and
thought is a type of form
so when I say form I mean like objects
distinctions of some kind this is blue
and not green this is up and not down I
feel you know well and not unwell
whatever my thoughts are like thoughts
are like little forms in the mind that
we fall asleep into
so I am hungry you know you have that
thought now I want to eat a sandwich I
gotta find a sandwich or I want to grab
the chips or whatever the moment that
you have that thought you have fallen
asleep
into being that thought now you are the
being who wants chips that's all that's
what you are because wow
so then when you think about whether
even the thought of whether or not
source is self-aware that's a thought
too that you're having from the human
personality's perspective and it's
valuable
but I'm saying that at the deepest
levels when you go all the way past all
the form
that's not empty it's full it's full of
beingness that transcends all form I
don't there's no words to use it that
knows itself very fully and completely
but in a way that is much bigger than
one specific definition in fact it gives
rise to the opportunity for all the
definitions that we're experiencing here
we're like looking back from the human
perspective and saying oh I understand
reality from the form perspective I
understand linear time and discrete
location and I understand ideas and
philosophy and then we write thousands
of books about philosophy and we try to
understand you know and then we spend
hours talking about all the different
forms that's that's good that's fine in
fact that's helping the all to know
itself from their perspective but I'm
just saying that deeper perspective it
fully transcends all those distinctions
that we could possibly throw on it have
you been drawn to plant medicine
experiences to bring you into those
spaces again to get access I personally
haven't
um personally I
I I'm interested in trying to navigate
the human limitations in a simple Lucid
way if I can without you know some kind
of physical influence in fact I've tried
binaural beats I don't even like
binaural beats you know two different
pitches one on each year I I don't
prefer that
um yeah
do you feel are you a highlight are you
highly sensitive oh yes oh yes I'm so
sensitive to everything that can usually
be a total reason why somebody I have
friends that are highly sensitive and
they're not drawn at all because it's
almost already sensory overload then the
idea of invoking even more is just
totally not a good idea
yeah I'm not looking for a new sense
experience I'm looking so what we're
what we're speaking to transcends even
the sensory it's it's a deeper no it's a
deeper state of being
um but yeah I understand what you're
saying and I'm definitely so sensitive
that I'm very careful about all that
stuff how has that affected you and your
life being so sensitive because that can
be an overwhelming feeling it's a it's
just some challenges yeah absolutely no
it's a daily it's a daily challenge for
me and I actually remember in my
pre-birth experience knowing that if I
because I asked to have a small amount
of memory this time and not forget
everything completely
and I knew that that would necessitate
sensitivity and that that would make the
life potentially even more challenging
but I knew that even that level of
contrast was an opportunity for growth
you know it was an opportunity
but now that I'm here I mean I have
sensitivities that just nobody else has
that I do like what every day like
sensitivities to different kinds of
light like for instance I have not been
able to find a computer monitor in the
last 10 years that I can tolerate I'm
using an old Monitor and sensitivity of
foods and sounds but I can also feel
non-physical
um uh I know this sounds wild but I can
sense non-physical information
and I think that goes hand in hand you
know like if I'm walking by someone I
might suddenly get
a knowing like we were describing in my
being in my body about who they are who
they really are and maybe maybe I hit
and what their personality is within
them and what they're experiencing and
I feel like that goes hand in hand and
the story and Beyond the story it's like
who they think they are and who like I
tend to sense a bit of the true nature
you know who who somebody is beneath the
character because that's who we really
are I love that I I relate to that on
some level for sure and the challenge in
that is trusting the information and
whether or not
you're just a good Storyteller do you
ever find that that it's hard to trust
either one or like getting used to
trusting it because at first you think
I'm just really good at telling stories
yeah personally I feel there's a
distinct difference because it's not an
Earthly like type of thought or story
it's a type of like vibration that's
very multi-textured not something I can
easily put a story on in fact sometimes
when I sense it and I try to share it I
I can't there's no words you know how do
you describe like an ocean of color or
something like not that I don't perceive
it visually typically but I'm just
saying it's beyond it's beyond that
language but I'm also you know
Discerning like I don't I'm not real big
on quick jumping to uh you know I sense
that I'm I'm very you know open-minded
but also skeptical and I try to always
have that healthy level of you know
discernment
but it's not something I go out and seek
you know it's just like almost like a
sense that is just so normal for me now
it's almost stronger than my other
senses sometimes
give yourself a really really normal
average guy and I do have a normal job
too yeah I do yeah I'm a project
come on man how does that work yeah or
how do you use it hang on that's
actually not not even fair
why aren't you just some very like you
know good psychic out there that can
help you know people figure out where
they're going or you know there are so
many so many jobs that would tap
directly into that awareness
um but how do you use it then because
it's totally possible to take our
special skills and inject them into
regular life
yeah that's a really good question I
navigate the regular life
every day in a way that I try to be the
most genuine and authentic I can and
utilize that experience because it is
spiritual too there's not like a
difference you know this entire
manifestation around us as dense as it
is is limiting as it is is Rich with
opportunity every day and that's true
even if interactions might be with you
know someone who's not fully aware of
the you know the higher nature of who we
are that's that's the norm here you know
we we're veiled as we as we walk around
um as as for not applying it in a um you
know in a professional sense I have not
personally felt super called to do that
um I have felt called to share messages
like this and and you know the writing
of my book I felt deeply deeply called
to to do that to provide that present
that
and then step away even you know and
then just let it let it go and let you
know let life happen as it will you know
your book is called a walk in the
physical and um it did I hear you say it
was free yeah I have a copy on my
website that can be read online for free
yep wow
um I'm it's not about the money it's
more important I feel just to share the
message it is available on Amazon or on
Audible
um I'm really touched by you know the
number of people who've reached out
about the book and you know it's funny
when I was writing so I say when I was
writing I actually don't even feel like
I wrote it all the way I feel like
chunks came to me over six years one bit
at a time and then when it when I made
it available I just I almost felt like
it wasn't mine I just it was something
that needed to be in the world and that
was it and now I feel like I could even
just walk away and it would be fine
so I'm I'm excited about it but I also
don't feel like oh it's my book
that's not really how it is there's
almost like a feeling like there's some
kind of imposter syndrome to try and
take credit for something you feel like
you didn't have to effort for because
like there's this seeming rule in Life
or unless you effort for something you
didn't really earn it what you're
describing is the true nature of
everyone though yeah you're just aware
you're doing it amen yeah I oh man and
that that's something that can't be you
know Quantified or monetized that's all
you know when we speak to the like
unconditional love is unconditional that
the true nature of spirit the true
nature of what we are and and the nature
of source is unconditional love fully
giving fully open
you know how can anybody like put a
price tag on there yeah the most
beautiful message that I got from my
most deepest soberist
experience was that there's no need for
forgiveness because there was never a
judgment in the first place that's how
pure the love is that's how true and
all-encompassing and deep and it's
literally everything it's just like
you're totally loved and there's no need
for forgiveness because there was never
even a judgment absolutely absolutely
totally unconditional love and it's like
we're already goodness
we're already innocent you know we just
fell asleep into the dream of form and
into the the fee so when we fall into
the dream of form we have fear because
we haven't yet fully integrated this and
when we have fear we have ego rise up
and the ego is just an attempt to fix
this huge fear problem that rose up now
and we're all running around like you
know a bunch of kindergarteners trying
to make ourselves feel better and you
know I'm I'm better now because I'm a
part of this group or I can have this
object or I can have this power you know
like whatever all the all the millions
of manifestations of ego but at the
heart Archer nature is already complete
love and joy and freedom and innocence
you know we are good at our very core
that is true of all people yeah I
actually really totally believe that too
even the ones that do bad things
you don't know what kind of experience
they had when they were young or what's
been passed on from the family
generation through cellular memory or
ancestral memory don't you don't know
what they thought they had to do to
survive oh yeah there's so much
conditioning and not just in one human
life too we're talking about a context
that's even much bigger than not a
history that's even much bigger but from
the spiritual perspective from the
higher perspective there's complete
understanding there's complete Vision
it's like oh I see exactly why you
experienced the way you did oh wow you
actually really were BR you know I mean
you see the amazing qualities of the
other
and there's just so much profound love
that rises up for the other I'm reminded
of an experience I had years ago where
this is early in my Awakening process
and I had an out-of-body experience
where I
I know this sounds strange as well but I
saw and felt the soul
of my wife's ex-boyfriend who at the
time I wasn't a fan of this is early in
my Awakening so I had silly ego you know
things going on there but I felt about
his nature the oh my goodness the the
the way that his spirit and my wife's
overlapped and how they shared this
beautiful creative power and that how
his being and my being overlapped and we
shared This Love Of Honor this like deep
deep ancient love of honor and I could
feel how in his life he had been
squashed by lack of love like he had
been born into a family where he was not
loved by his parents and it felt like a
car tire that rolled over Plato and
flattened it super super thin and then
from that thinness he's trying to live
and create and I was oh my gosh I have
so much honor I I just respect and love
this man so much and now when I see him
I mean now we're close And now when he
comes over every time I see him I feel
like kneeling to the guy because I'm
like I cannot believe so much he's doing
so much with so little I'm like I can't
believe what you're doing here on Earth
you're this is amazing I just want to
honor his journey and that's how it is
from Spirit for all of us you know we're
seeing for the rigor that we've had to
operate in and through yeah talk about
the um uh first off I want to go to the
in-between and then I want to work into
like reincarnation the choices and all
that okay but what is that in between
life like not life what is the in
between a human life like and is is that
essentially what you were seeing in that
pre-birth experience is the in-between
yeah so okay so
this context is very vast
so we like to narrow it down to simple
there's like Earth level and then
there's like in between level and then
tell me about that level you know yeah
because here on Earth that's kind of how
we think of places you know well even on
Earth think of how many places there are
and we are and we're in a very limiting
system right so so I'm just saying that
as a context because the the scope of
being and the scope of activity that is
available to the soul when not limited
to an Incarnation is
unspeakably vast yeah but I but I can at
least say in my from my experience I
remember having experiences in different
layers that led up to the choice to
Incarnate and to be a Christian
and I remember being in a realm of
Golden Light I remember this being
coming to me and asking me if I wanted
to go back yet if I was ready yet and
then reviewing this life
um I had a previous Incarnation attempt
first that did not work out because I
rejected it out of fear
and anyway so that whole process takes
place in a similar level and there is
there are many different places in it
but they're they're transverse by
thought alone and tension so you just
intend or you want to be somewhere and
you're there
and there's so many different aspects of
that I can't possibly
put language on it I can say the closest
to when I actually incarnated like again
this transcends linear time too so
that's really hard really hard to speak
to but at the point that was closest to
Incarnation I was in a place that
appeared to be as an example we like
environment so I can at least describe
one environment I was in this room that
looked like a technician's chamber and
it was over the Earth and there was like
a shaft leading down to the Earth and
there were these beings there that are
like Veil application technicians
something like that
um and that place was very close
vibrationally to Earth but still you
know pre-incarnation so I still had all
my knowing I could see the Earth but I
wasn't in that layer you know I wasn't I
was not that vibrational density that
the Incarnation process is like a
plummet of vibration down down down down
down to resonate into this comparatively
very very dense uh experience by
comparison
oh
in a way you don't really actually go
anywhere exactly that's the exactly
everything and everywhere you don't go
anywhere you just lower your frequency
down so much to
experience this super dense linear
time-consuming fear-based reality
exactly exactly you're like wow that's
the freaking that's the we're having oh
my God being a human is The Dark Knight
of the Soul itself
that's that's it is it's the it's the
most dense most opportunity offering
limiting see those are synonymous
opportunity offering and limiting are
synonymous
opportunity that's handed to us and we
that's right we don't actually ever
leave it's like the experience plays
upon the movie screen of our awareness
and we seem to be locked into it I mean
of course that's the very nature of
being veiled it seems like this is all
there is that's the name of the game but
our Consciousness is actually still
there you could say that a subset of the
self is like committed into the physical
experience but the whole self is always
outside of it it's like you could say
metaphorically it's like falling asleep
in heaven to have the dream of verb you
know when you wake up in the morning you
know you never left your bed similarly
when you wake up after physical death
you know you never left you never were
in any real danger well I get very
tripped out on how the universe works
and and sort of
the fractal nature of it and how you
know there's just it's hard to put into
words I can kind of like feel this sort
of looping almost and it's like like a
black hole almost like it sucks it in
and then no new galaxies are born and
it's like it feels like there's almost
an aspect within us that does that and
because there's no other I'm trying to I
try and rationalize and maybe we're just
not even capable of it as human beings
so maybe it's not within our sort of
data Computing capabilities but
things like quantum entanglement and
things like I just it can't we can't
imagine that with our linear life that
we live here that something on opposite
ends of the universe can communicate
instantaneously that's because the
universe is virtual it's all being
simulated at once so the the
communication is outside of the universe
because that which is generating the
universe is already connected to itself
it doesn't need distance distances
distance is an illusion
you can think of it that way just like
we we believe in distance you know a lot
but distance is just a visual experience
a sensory experience an idea it's all
these forms it's a it's an illusion
um but anyway I like what you said about
the fractal nature of reality because it
very much is like that uh you know so
Above So Below you know as it said the
the quality of the spirit is such that
we do have fractals of being you know
you have the source that has
individuated into drops you have each
drop each soul that is individuated into
different personalities that appear from
a given personality's perspective is
separate but they're not separate
they're one you know you are all your
characters that you've played or the
same you
anyway so it is like that it's like a
huge fractal system within consciousness
I was just um I interviewed a guy named
uh chervin he has a cool company called
symbiotica and he's uh he's
um very spiritual and has been sort of
walking in these this is the world for
uh like since he was like 10. and we
were talking about the you know evil
forces that would be controlling the
planet and is there an Illuminati or a
cabal or is there a a deep State and
it's he described it in a way that was
like it's not that there's a group
and we kind of deduced it down to the
fact that it's like it's actually
just a macro of the micro which is that
it's an aspect within us like this sort
of like greed or materialism it's on the
micro version it's an aspect within us
and that the real solution is not
necessarily to point the finger and be a
victim it's to fix it within yourself
because when we all do that it's all
fixed absolutely the the simplest way I
feel to put that is that it's all fear
fear that is we've rejected something
we're we're not okay with something and
so we grab for control that's what the
ego does and that happens in many
different layers it happens in groups it
happens in individuals but the thing is
that that external environment is not
the active playing field for real change
I mean it will it will fix itself if
the real environment is addressed and
that is consciousness itself so the
simplest way to put that is face your
own fear
own your own crap in your life and find
the joy and the love that you already
are that got buried underneath all these
other things maybe even got buried at
the moment you incarnated now you're
physical you don't like being separate
from everybody else that's okay find the
real you in there face to fear process
it allow it that actually helps the
entire Collective to heal because we're
all connected like we're a part of one
Pond one soup and when one of us does
that and really finds the love and
processes the fear it's like a light
that goes off for everybody else in the
pond and it raises the temperature of
the water for the whole pond so we're
not powerless you know we tend to look
external all the time oh look at the
political parties look at the laws look
at the the
face your own fear and know that there's
nothing to fear and that you are love
and you are joy and if you find that in
your life you will change the world
you'll just uh that vibration will
affect the whole world rather than being
lost in this idea of hopelessness that
we can't affect the world that's it's
not true there's a thought that you know
there's like the three waves of
volunteers that someone like Dolores
Cannon has made pop you know popularized
um crystal children indigo children
um star seeds that that these are all
you know
waves of entities that come and
incarnate as a human to help the planet
is that true yeah I believe I believe it
is true so I didn't have specific
experience with the the three waves of
Volunteers in my pre-birth experience
but I did know from the previous
standpoint it was just like seen as
just obvious that the Earth is going
through an Awakening process and that's
very exciting it's like the it's like
the uh the act of the play is the
Awakening act and so there is a
uh I'll just simply say this I feel like
there was a calling
for those who are able to contribute to
come and participate because if if we
have higher vibrational nature I don't
mean that in a duality sense because I'm
not trying to compare anybody to anybody
else that's not like that but if we have
experience in higher systems and we're
loving and involved and we come into the
Human Experience even if we don't
remember which we don't typically and
even if we don't know exactly what we're
doing the our mere presence
affects the pond because now we're a
part of it and our vibration is
automatically affecting the vibration of
the whole pond so a lot of the younger
people today are very loving and wise
beings and you know they've come into
this world and we'll see we'll see what
happens it's exciting what did they what
to do what
so the yeah so the Earth is going
through an Awakening process which just
means we are processing our old fear
crap
and moving vibrationally closer to what
we really are which is love
and acceptance and freedom and joy
there is a huge vibrational distance
though because the human Collective
Consciousness has a long history with
all sorts of nastiness all sorts of
fear-based ego patterns
but those ego patterns are are being
faced and processed by many individuals
and so we might see on the surface
there's a lot of conflict at times well
that crap has to come up and be seen in
order to be processed and faced and felt
and healed and so that healing that
happens is something that changes the
collective Consciousness it sets a new
momentum a new Direction which
continually raises the temperature of
the water that's just the metaphor for
raising the vibration of the human
consciousness that is happening it is in
the process now like I'm energetically
sensitive like I mentioned so I feel
like when I go into larger groups I can
feel the difference now compared to even
10 years ago there's there's still
there's a there's quite a notable
difference and we might look on the
surface and say oh man everything is a
mess
well there's a lot of fear in there but
this is happening we are Awakening and
and Love is Growing actually I agree
with you I mean as much as it's scary
and nasty out there the conversation
we're having and some a lot of the other
conversations I have on the show are
just even with my friends are not
conversations that you could have with
almost everybody yeah and that's
probably why I mean it wasn't all that
long ago that you came forward with your
story right yeah that's right I so my
body is 43 right now I was about 38 I
believe when I came out with my story
but my pre-birth memory returned at the
age of 30. so there was about eight
years that I didn't share I didn't feel
like it was appropriate I didn't want to
take that professional risk you know but
then I just had the sense like okay the
ground is fertile enough now like the
soil is just just fertile enough
and so I shared and I'm very glad that I
did the island is just big and
big and so long like even when I started
you know getting very interested and
deep into spirituality and Curiosities
of that in all aspects of it yeah I just
was thought of as weird like I remember
being called weird and it was like I
felt like I was on an island right oh
yeah yeah you know you feel like you're
on an island so your Island got bigger
oh my well there's uh I can say with
certainty there are thousands of people
out there who I mean Millions even who
feel like that underst they sense even
if they don't know what it is that
there's more going on than what they see
on the surface and a lot of people have
experiences and just don't have anybody
to share them with you know and I feel
like that's one of the greatest
blessings since I've shared is I've been
able to meet so many amazing people
there are a lot out there did you come
into awareness that there was ever a
point in time on this planet where we
were like the Golden Age was there ever
a point in time where it was love it was
coherence there was peace there was a
higher vibrational operating level or is
this been a sort of gradual increase
since Inception of the planet 4.3
billion years ago or whatever it was I
don't know I don't know I would guess
the second one but I I don't know
because you said you like you aborted
the previous life to this one because
fear took over and was too much and um
so
do we choose the life that we have oh
yes parents do we choose our friends do
we incarnate with a soul family to make
it easier like how is it that we come
into the experience that we're having in
this life yeah so we absolutely choose
to come I know that that's strange when
so many people feel that their lives are
difficult and you know they're suffering
and so many people say I would never
sign up for this you know we have really
big balls when we're on the other side
we're like I got this I mean I think
that about myself as I say that to
myself regular I'm like Danica seriously
what did you sign up for what did you
what did you think that you had the
balls for okay so it's so funny because
what you just described I actually
remember doing so I remember seeing the
vibrational distance and going holy crap
that is further than I've ever done
can it even be done you know because it
was so like in my case it was a one very
specific vibration one fear that I came
to process and heal and it was so so so
vibrationally low that I was like how is
it even possible and I was told yes it
is and I just knew like if it could be
done
then I'll do then I will do it because I
know I knew what we are you know we are
unlimited Immortal beings who can't fail
we can't fail like we can't actually
fail but we can like get underneath the
weight bunch and put 150 or 200 or 500
pounds on there
and give it a shot you know and then
once we get underneath the weight that
the thing about this weight bench is
once you're strapped into the roller
coaster you can't get off you know
that's that's the but that's the name of
the game we want to be committed into a
context that we can't easily Escape
that way we have to be quote unquote
forced
to face ourselves to face our
limitations to face our fears to
overcome them to see if we can really be
there for each other and compassion and
love and kindness even when it's hard
you know so anyway we do see that
context pre-life and everybody has a
different um you know intentionality
behind their Incarnation it's very
specific to the soul and their qualities
and what they what they're interested in
and specific to the life and the context
there's a huge variety there
um so I can't speak to everybody but I
can at least say that yes we we do
review the context
and it does it is it is a necessity that
it be a choice volunteer voluntary
because the soul the spirit is Sovereign
it's a part of source it there's no
greater Authority nothing can lock it
away nothing can nothing can limit it
unless it limits itself unless it
surrenders itself into a limitation by
itself within itself which is what we do
so I so my memory then of I saw I
remember surrendering to the Veil
and that process of giving over my
knowing and giving over my power and
surrendering and even that prompting
that initial fear because that's a huge
loss of control why the hell do we do it
is it exciting like do we look at this
malt like fraction of time that we
experience and and we go back to
our more of our true nature and it was a
great experience no matter what it was
like it was like wow that was a thriller
it's like going into a movie that you
got really scared in but you came out
you're like oh my God that was crazy was
it yeah okay that's not a bad metaphor
or is it because there is truly like
something happening that has a ripple
effect into the universe and we're
helping with it like is there a bigger
purpose other than just like that was
fun yeah both and the latter is that we
are participating in the expansion of
love and joy
through Evolution we're evolving that's
just a simple word that's a simple
English word but I'm speaking about the
evolution of spirit that is the
refinement of spirit now at the same
time it's already perfect so I know this
sounds like a paradox from duality's
point of view
but when applied into the imperfect into
duality we are imperfect
at a given point we're only so good at
manifesting and manifesting as maybe the
wrong word we're only so good at
actualizing our true loving nature in a
given context at a given point in time
and we seek to push the boundaries
and see how much more can we do and how
much more can we know like actually feel
and experience contrast is like a gift
because it gives you the opportunity to
experience the low so that you can also
know the high at the same time it's
maybe like if you take a balloon
and you blow up the balloon
and you make it really big and then you
lock it in place you tie it now it's
stuck with all this air in it it's a
little bit like what we've done here
we've come vibrationally down down down
down down we've been locked into a
position now in this position
can you make the loving choice in this
position can you feel a certain emotion
how do you respond to it in this
position can you find who you really are
can you love the person next to you can
you know Joy here can you overcome fear
how do you respond to pain or loss in
this position and then when you take the
position back away now see all that work
that you did out here is magnified by
that distance you did the work at you
know that that depth of your it's like a
depth of being that is um I don't want
to use the word carved out because that
sounds pretty gruesome but a depth of
being that is refined and deepened and
then when you take that depth of being
into other thought responsive reality
systems it has an impact immediately
like I was inspired to Incarnate because
I could see and feel from a being who
had incarnated oh my gosh he was full of
so much power and joy he was able to
feel Joy that I couldn't even understand
I I picture it almost like a food
pyramid and how like in a food pyramid
like if you are the very top stop it's
like if you come down to earth to this
like big base level but you actually
shift and change the big Pace level it
it it affects everything like yes
there's no it's like foundational it's
essentially your foundational
awareness foundational frequency like it
richens
the rest yes it enriches the whole and
the foundational level is actually where
we start but but yes it is like going
down down down and then
it's like if you put on a 20 pound coat
or a 50 pound coat or a hundred pound
coat you get to pick which one you want
and then you go go for a run
you know and then you come back and you
take the coat off and you're like oh my
gosh that was heavy but now you're
stronger in a way that you now you may
have been enabled to do something or
know something or even feel something
that someone else who hasn't worn that
coat hasn't felt and so there's this
Allure you could say of vibrational
distance the deeper the vibrational
distance the more the opportunity and so
that's why a lot of souls are like oh
man sign me up man put me in for the
yeah give me the hard class give me the
hard stuff you know and then there's
usually the guides who are like okay I
think you're biting off a little too
much this time let's rain that back in a
little bit and you're like oh but I want
to do it all at once I want to you know
just chill out a little bit and try to
find you know an evening I'm glad you
mentioned she died because that was what
I wanted to ask next was about guides
angels
um ascended masters ancient goddesses
like you know ancient Egyptian or Greek
or you know
what do you know about that because that
all just seems like
such a mystery land of like were they
real were they not were they just
stories to help with understanding and
coping were they re you know what what
are they were they extraterrestrials
yeah do they live in all Realms like is
it just a frequency like what what role
do
um guides and angels and ascended
masters play yeah we can just say this
Consciousness we are Consciousness your
Consciousness I'm Consciousness so is
every other being
Consciousness has a huge variety of
experiential opportunity given to it we
don't have to be physically incarnated
that's just one thing not everybody goes
to college or not everybody goes to you
know Cedar Point and rides a roller
coaster that's something you can choose
to do if you want but not everybody does
that
so I'm just saying there's a huge
variety of of individuals you could say
individuals whether they're physically
incarnated or not
and individuals tend to grow through
experience in or evolve in certain
qualities and so then beings who are
very Adept at certain qualities tend to
be able to help others with those
qualities and we call those guides
guides could be beings who have been
physically incarnated or beings who have
not but they might be really good at a
certain vibration we also tend to have
personal guides got a being that knows
us really well and tends to kind of
follow us and track US throughout the
process I've heard that we all have like
one main guide one or a few yeah or a
few or like three or four or something
but I know it's really well
you know and so there's a huge variety
to what that might mean
um some beings are incredibly evolved
and powerful and
so I mean you know it's hard to get into
too many specifics but I'm trying to
give a broad I'm trying to make a broad
comment because there's such a breadth
to what a guide could be or who a guy
might be it could be a living person
that we knew physically who passed on
and they have a relationship with us and
they love us and because they love us
they come back and they just kind of
watch over and they know from that side
oh wow that was a cool video game
and then from that point of view they
can maybe help or guide or nudges and
then when we when we exit the game
they're there for us you know so that's
just another possibility yeah send a
masters we might put in that category
too those are beings who have had a lot
of I mean I tend to think of ascended
masters as beings who have a lot of
incarnational experiences and have
basically mastered the course the
college you know the the physical
Universe experience has been mastered
Jesus Krishna Buddha right those kinds
of I mean you know um right onion or
Green Tara or
you know mother Mary or Magdalene Mary
Magdalene those kinds right yeah yeah I
mean I'm not gonna label any given
person with any given title but yes that
that's right beings who have mastered
the course you know and and no longer
respond in fear so what does that what
does that mean mastering I mean it has
to do with fully integrating the breadth
of experience that is possible here such
that they are able to bring love into
all context even say being hung on a
cross as an example right so you say the
names don't matter but if these are
Ascent if these ascended masters are to
help us and they are helpful they have
they are able to attune to a certain
frequency that they're most helpful with
um yeah I didn't mean to say the names
don't matter I just meant I didn't want
to draw a distinction between oh this
person isn't a senate master and that
one isn't I'm not going to do that but
the names are to be able to access the
free access that frequency tune into it
so it's helpful to still address them
right it's still you know if you want to
say like you know Jesus I need your help
with this like what does that do yeah
it's like a Google search
um except in spirit the Google search
engine's way better way faster and
always listening
um
and you're so it's your intention that
is really entering the search engine and
the name or the form is just the way you
know that by the system can interpret
that very successfully so like you know
you don't even need to call person by
their name in your mind of course you
know if you have a loved one that passed
you don't need to say okay loved one
name so and so you know if you if you
just intend and you have that love in
your heart and you reach out with your
mind and with your intention it's
intention is the movement of
Consciousness that is automatically
having an effect same thing with uh
calling out to an ascended Master for
instance is it easy for you to have this
kind of intentional dialogue with
any entity or energy that you want
uh no I'm quite veiled
I'm very much veiled and I'm thankful
that I am
but I do um I feel that I have a
constant interaction with spirit and and
God you could say
um I'm not super careful in my own mind
about different distinctive names
because I've because once you sense the
Oneness of being that we are
there's like all the form definitions
and walls are so much less relevant you
know they're just much less relevant I'm
not saying they're not important but
they're they're less relevant if you
were to call out whatever you feel like
your greatest skill or spiritual skill
is what is it oh boy
um I am deeply at a soul level
interested in
understanding DeMent cross-dimensional
expression and how do I describe this
it's really hard to describe these
things cross-dimensional knowing and
like a system context Mastery and then
being able to hopefully quantify it in a
concise way I love that and I feel like
like my book A Walk in the physical for
instance is my attempt and as a physical
human
to try to bring down that very vast and
succinct digestible language
and that's something that my soul loves
to do you know I don't I will say a
skill or whatever we all do have things
we're strong at
um
I feel like that cross-dimensional uh
proficiency might say is something that
is a great joy to me
helped you in your life
that's what we are
um I mean when you know what we really
are we are Joy so the question is a
little bit like saying how does Joy help
you in your life it's Joy is not about
unnecessarily even a physical outcome
it's just when you know Joy it's
wonderful because that's what we are and
when we can feel joy and know that Joy
here wow you know because here like I
said we're locked all the way out in
this position if we can find who we are
here and express it and share it with
each other and love each other and
really authentically meet each other
even in a simple way like a small way
oh my gosh it's so powerful I I take joy
in that if if possible I mean I'm still
very much veiled I have my own personal
great limitations I have fear still of
course you know I have challenges like
every other human of course
but the question is what do we do with
the challenges
and how do we allow that true nature to
meet the challenges like honestly
authentically really honest with
ourselves where am I weak
What Fear have I locked away that I
don't want to feel today what feeling
have I do I not want to feel today what
what self-belief or you know whatever
whatever the thing is that's triggering
anytime we feel anything negative
anything negative what is the illusion
that I have bought into
right I love the idea that
um or the visualization or embodied
feeling of that if sort of anything
feels uncomfortable or
um feels bad is because whatever that
thing is is out of resonance with your
true self that's right your true self is
never that so if you don't feel good
it's because you're out of resonance
something is putting you in a position
yeah so you have to do something or say
something or be someone and it's not who
you are yeah you've bought into a
self-perception that is not in alignment
with the truth of who you are so so for
instance deep down if on the surface it
might be this person flicked me off in
the interstate and now I'm mad
but deep underneath all the layers of
ego what really might be going on is I
feel powerless and I'm upset that I feel
powerless whatever it is whatever that
negative self-perception at the root is
that you think reality is proving to you
that negative self-perception of feeling
either powerless or Unworthy of love
or you know some of the other like I'm
not free that's another big one not
having freedom those are not in
alignment with the truth the truth is
you are a powerful being you are
unconditionally loved you are love
itself
and you are completely and totally free
but when you lose yourself in the idea
of not being free that hurts that
triggers fear when you lose yourself in
the idea of being shameful Unworthy of
love that sucks because it's not true
and so whenever we have that negative we
can honestly look inside of ourselves
and say where do I have fear and what
negative self-perception has the world
seemed to prove to me the illusion of
the world I might add has it seemed to
prove to me
is real it's just it's not really
fundamentally real but it's giving you
the opportunity to be really in your
face
and really give you the chance to to
identify with potentially these
perceptions and play with them what kind
of powers do we have here I get that
we're infinite beings we're of like all
these things but
like doesn't feel practical what are our
tools here and what maybe what are our
tools right now and what do we where are
we stepping what are we stepping into
because it does feel like we're stepping
into something we're moving into another
level of us that has access to more of
something so what are our tools here
right now and what should we be working
to cultivate right so on a practical
level we are constantly affecting
reality physical reality all the time
like we're nudging the probabilities all
the time I know most people believe in
an objective material world it's only it
only appears to be an objective material
world
it's actually probabilistic in nature
Our intention does affect outcome all
the time so that's just one thing so
it's not it's not predetermined it's a
probabilistic reality where intention is
constantly nudging all the time all the
time
so I'm just pointing out that mechanism
but but what's the power behind that
mechanism and that is intent our true
power is our intent
what are we really intending In This
Moment how are we how are we really
using this moment you could say the most
direct way to comment that question is
what is your relationship to this moment
are you making it an enemy
or are you in love with it is it in love
with you
if it's not in love with you and you're
not in love with it that's okay find out
where you bought into something that
made it an enemy oh because but I but I
went through years and years of trauma
and I was I'm you know whatever the
story is that immediately Rises up in
anger because the ego is pissed you know
it raises its righteous Fist and it says
I have good reason to call this universe
cruel and me a victim are you willing to
let go of that actually and find how you
actually do have the power to even feel
that negative fear whatever it was you
locked away whatever it was that all
those years of abuse or whatever it was
seemed to prove to you are you willing
to actually go feel that and honor
yourself love yourself enough to
actually meet your own experience all
the way
now that may sound indirect to your
question but it's not it's not indirect
because the quality of our experience
directly is reflective of the quality of
what we've done within ourselves as
Spirit when you go into these dark
aspects of yourself of something you
fear or something that you're jealous of
or something that you're angry about
um
you know you have to go through the pain
it's like
on a micro level that's what's happening
here on Earth but on a macro level you
go I'm going to go into this Incarnation
to learn this thing to elevate to a
higher level out here and it's just sort
of just bigger and smaller versions of
it you know but they're all the self
there's an important Point here that I
think is often missed so sometimes when
we hear a conversation like this we
think oh there's something I need to do
and the thing I need to do is to go you
know face my fears and do these things
okay that's true but but there's
something deeper than the doing and that
is your actual willingness
to feel or to be or to do whatever
and I'm pointing that up because you
mentioned avoiding pain willingness to
feel the pain
this willingness I'm talking about means
for the pain that you've buried away
your whole life this is not about
avoiding that anymore if if you really
want to open up all the gates it's about
actually being willing to go feel the
pain
willing that means you no longer make an
enemy you say you know what I feel
powerless to this but I'm going to feel
it anyway I'm gonna go see I'm gonna go
into the dark closet and see is this
thing really going to destroy me or not
and that requires feeling
it's a very personal and genuine and
real process it's not about you know
like as humans on the surface we're all
about activity do this activity get this
result tell me what activity I can do so
I can get away from this pain that I I
have
this is more than activity it's who you
are it's it's the actual quality of
choice that you make and the universe
that's what it's watching it's not
watching necessarily the activity
it's watching your willingness to admit
your your your issues to all in yourself
to own your pain to feel your pain to
actually help the person next to you to
actually be willing to actually choose
Joy even though that might mean that you
have to be vulnerable to be full of joy
right now to be a little kid and run
around and play in the Sun
yeah you know what I mean like that's a
quality of being choice is all I'm
saying it's not primarily about an
action where are we going are are humans
not going to be humans as we know it or
something completely different like yeah
where are we going I'm understanding
your question to me where are we going
as a physical species but I want to
comment in the context though that we're
not human
I know that sounds totally crazy I know
that we're I know that sounds totally
crazy but we're not human you're you
you're the you that feels like you to
you that's who you are and you just you
think that you means human really deeply
but that's not that's not that's not
what you are so where are we going we
are the players We Are the souls we're
going even beyond the limitation of The
Human Condition we're going to
into experiences I can't possibly even
imagine yet name but as a physical
species the physical species will end up
over time reflecting more and more that
Limitless nature of spirit it just might
take what we would consider a long time
right which is not a big deal to Spirit
linear times of creation anyway it's not
a big deal
do you remember other lives that you had
non-human or
I have some yeah I have some Snippets
fan of exists of experiences that you
remember well I know I've had hundreds
of other Incarnation incarnitive
experiences but I only remember Snippets
from a few I remember a couple that are
non-human and I remember one as a human
woman so if I get curious and I try to
investigate I usually get this gentle
nudge like no you don't need to go see
that right now and I'm fine with that
you're like okay no problem you know I'm
Christian right now so I know that I've
had other experiences
um and when I say I've had other
experiences that's really important it's
not because sometimes I think when we
think of reincarnation
we think though those are other people
and I'm them no it's you it's the same
like if you go do something on Monday
night and then you go to something on
Tuesday night like you go to dinner one
night go to a movie the next night go to
a race car track the next night whatever
it is
still you going to each of those
experiences there's not really a
different person you might be a slightly
different person on Tuesday night than
you were on Monday night and you might
be a slightly different person on
Wednesday night than Tuesday night
that's how it is as a soul we have one
experience and then we have another
experience but it's the same you so
you're never not going to be you
processing trauma and going into these
dark spaces that we're afraid to go and
becoming a different person or being
afraid almost that you'll become a
different person it's like you'll never
lose your essence ever absolutely like
you'll your your your home frequency
that people feel won't ever change it's
really just about you chain how you feel
in that frequency like that's the crazy
thing about growth and like becoming
more of an observer and not getting so
wrapped up in things and getting so
pulled and torn and victim and that and
oh my gosh that and Division and it's
like you actually your reality sometimes
changes there's definitely no bones
about it like sometimes some things in
your reality change but for the most
part you just feel better in it yeah so
what feels not good
is when you've associated with things
that you're not
right that's what feels not good
fakeness
uh negative self-perceptions that aren't
you
yeah you know that's what that's what
doesn't feel good the the real you is
full of you're joyful you're a joyful
being you are you just it and I like you
know you might you might say no no no I
have this long story like I said all
this history that proves to me that
that's not true that's okay
you've had that experience now now what
you're still you you're still the joyful
you underneath all those layers always
yeah it's it's really a message of hope
I mean we just we come so far deep into
this Human Experience we really get lost
in the story and it's an opportunity
it's a gift and we've become so lost now
that we kind of made it into a little
bit of a nightmare sometimes you know
what I mean but now that we're here we
we still haven't we never lose who we
really are the question is what do we do
now in this moment with remembering even
just a little bit when I say remember
who you are I don't mean you need to
have a big like big old you know Grand
experience I'm talking like when you
look at the Sunset and you feel the joy
in your body
or you feel like oh my gosh like life is
good
and notice how that is not just a
feeling or an idea it's your very stuff
your very nature your being your
Consciousness itself actually is that
reflecting back to you in the form of a
sunset that's all
it's beautiful speaking of reflecting
back Soul families there's soul mates
there's twin flames and how we are this
we're on Earth but there is also other
fractions of us and that we may be split
off and you know there's a twin flame
somewhere out there and it might not be
even a human right but there's another
essence or there's or there's many I've
also heard there's many
so I don't know if on the other side you
were able to see whether or not there
are sort of really close home
frequencies and also maybe your own home
frequency within incarnations oh well we
do have our own home frequency We Are
Who We Are beautifully wonderfully the
idea of twin flame has several different
meanings some people talk about it as
being a romantic soul mate is most
optimal for you some people reference it
as another incarnation of the Same Soul
you know you another portion of you I
don't know much about how often that
happens I do know that the soul
incarnates and does multiple things at
the same time so it's not definitely not
off the table in fact I think it does
happen that the soul has multiple it can
play multiple personalities at once even
within the same time period I have no
idea how common that is
um but that whole vibration that you are
is always you and then that vibration is
more or less resonant with others
um and in higher systems there's like a
vibrational geography going on you know
like here on Earth I mentioned this
before but this is the place where you
can put two people in a room and now
they got to be stuck together you know
like that kind of thing they might be
discordant and yet they're in a room
together typically in higher systems you
go where you vibrate you go where you
resonate with you know you are what you
are and you fit over here and you prefer
over here I mean I'm being I'm being
General in that but that still then
happens someone on Earth just in a
slower way so we tend to attract others
that we resonate with on some level
whether it be a fear that we're trying
we're manifesting or you know a deeper
Soul quality or something else
yeah yeah cool well that's good it's
good to know we got some family out
there that we're awesome certain
frequency that is closer to whatever we
are and and look if that shifts and
evolves over time into different
frequencies and groups then so be it
that's what we're here to do right yeah
we're we are all family actually there's
no such thing as a stranger strangers
only happen when we have the illusion of
separation and then we don't remember
and we don't feel connected so we think
external people that we have no history
with are strangers that's what we call
Strangers but truly we're all connected
we're all brothers and sisters every
every one of us not just humans but
animals we're all about the
extraterrestrials it's the same there's
not there's not a big difference between
like I know that sounds super crazy
because oh my gosh now we're talking
about ETS but the soul has many
different opportunities to Incarnate not
just human not just Earth okay Earth
Earth is precious it's very unique I I
was able to feel and know the incredible
unique preciousness of Earth
but it's not the only show in town it's
not the only class you can go to it's
not the only place there's other systems
with incredibly different vibrations not
just in our entire universe but there
are entire other universes available I
mean this is a huge context so yes
they're all so Multiverse yes a
Multiverse so we are brothers and
sisters with the other beings that might
not be physical either like like I said
you're not a human we're not human
were us were you and you're you and I'm
I mean that's what we are we're just
playing human
do you think that we'll have true real
contact and knowledge and confirmation
of extraterrestrials on Earth or is that
yeah I think it's inevitable yeah
yeah have you ever have you met that did
you no I have no I have no direct
experience with what we would call an ET
I do have one
uh memory of what I suspect was probably
a
don't want to label it in any way but an
intelligent civilization that was not
human I think I have at least one
experience in that but other than that
I've had no direct experiences myself
with what we would call
ETS I have interacted at times with
other being other people's guides or
their deeper selves but I'm going to
draw a big distinction like I said it's
not really the form and it's hard to
speak to yeah so much of it is but I
think you do such an incredible job of
being able to articulate and truly all
you need is really one of these kinds of
mystical experiences to be able to
hear what you're saying and and because
you do actually put words to it that
resonate that that's why your story is
so important and why so many people have
paid attention to it is because you're
able to put words to it so I know it's a
struggle but we all appreciate you doing
it thank you just one small comment that
it's not that you need to have an
experience I heard you say there that it
might trigger an experience its
experiences may happen I mean out of
body experiences are more real than this
they're very real and Lucid but you
don't need to have that kind of
experience
who you really are like basically follow
your intuition feel inside yourself who
who are you and what does your Deeper
Self say is the path toward that maybe
it's letting go of something maybe it's
a habit maybe it's uh some self-belief
that you need to investigate or some
self-worth or you know that you can lift
up or whatever everybody is unique so
I'm just lifting that up because it
doesn't need to be some Grand experience
you know we we are Spirit having a human
experience that's just what we are so
the question then is as spirit because
you are Spirit right now as Spirit who
is in the middle of the play
how do you Intuit how do you feel is the
best way to nurture that and to find
that here while you're on Earth you're
allowed to do it there's actually no
reason you can't wake up to all that you
are here there's no like hard rule
against it really yeah the veil works
it's super effective but the thing is
this is a a stage that we get to use how
we choose it's completely up to us and
if we would like to wake up and go oh my
gosh I'm on a stage why is everybody so
serious
we're allowed to do that if we want or
we can or we can lose ourselves you know
in the drama and play some drama for a
while that's fine 100 that might be a
fun little fraction of your experience
they go like that lifetime was like
crazy
um well I I mean I I I yes but I also in
some of my experience one in particular
experience on psilocybin like
I knew I wasn't human
and I asked when I came back and I
realized because there is so much
information in that space it was like
question answer question answer but but
simultaneous almost like telepathy level
speed right where you just and I go I
can't I said how am I going to bring
this information back to the humans and
the information and the energy was like
you don't need to just you're fine don't
worry about it and
um then when I wanted to be human I
realized that I had to choose them I had
to choose the mind as the first like
Baseline
um Baseline construct to build this
reality and in the process I went oh my
God this is why we forget because in the
first space where I knew I wasn't human
I couldn't have been because I was so so
so so fully embodied not human that I
don't know how I could have been so I
asked the same thing you did I said can
I remember a little
can I like remember just a little so
that I can bring something back and so
you know I guess for whatever whatever
it is that I am giving to people as
information is like the little I
remember
that's beautiful I love it so much
it makes me so excited it's like trying
to download the entire internet through
a you know through a landline connection
or something yeah
that's gonna happen and then and then
someone's like here and they hand you a
straw and they're like okay now tell us
about the ocean it's like oh that can't
that's not happening but the thing is
you are the ocean like right now
like you're back you're back like here
you are right you've collapsed to back
down you're folded back down into the
limited human mind you're doing an
awesome thing an awesome job you're
sharing this information you're being
live you're sharing love it's beautiful
and now you're here but you're but the
video is still the big you it never went
anywhere never shifted so like that is
kind of like widening the straw in a
sense you know allowing that to flow
through and remind others of their
oceans
it's like an aperture
right like you're not ever not the whole
thing that's right but you just narrow
narrow narrow narrow narrow into this
very small spectrum and you go this is
my aperture it doesn't mean this isn't
there and happening it's just this is
where I'm looking right now and that my
experience is that the more spiritual
the more sort of higher vibrational
frequency
well whatever I don't even know exactly
the right words to put to it is that you
just kind of increase the aperture a
little bit yeah that's that's really
cool I love it it's a great analogy I
just want to come I want to comment so
part of increasing the aperture I think
when people talk about that they think
oh increasing aperture means leaving the
physical leaving you know all I am as a
human well actually if you through
meditation if you totally investigate
your awareness what you really are
underneath thinking
you create some space through which you
see the thoughts for what they are
and then you can actually with full
alertness be human like actually oh wow
I actually have these thoughts oh wow I
actually have this discomfort in my body
oh wow I'm actually afraid because I
feel old or you know whatever it is
whatever the thing is that that you're
dealing with
processing that widens the aperture it's
not like you're trying to leave all the
physical stink so I'm gonna try to leave
well you know you're never really all
the way here anyway but once you fully
integrate what's here the aperture can't
help it widen because now you're no
longer limited
um there's a metaphor too for this when
my father was a little kid I mentioned
this in the book he was afraid of a
closet in his room when he was going to
sleep every night as a child and every
night he would lay there in bed and he
would be terrified of what was in the
closet
and one night he's like screw this I am
sick of being afraid of this closet so
he charged into the closet pushed his
way through the clothes and sat down on
the on the floor he fully expecting to
be eaten by the monsters in the closet
he was not eaten by the monsters in the
closet and to this day my father is not
afraid of closets now I know that sounds
silly but our fears are not that
dissimilar we may have difference in
scope we may have had years of abuse or
years of pain
whatever but when you really go into it
when you really go into that dark cloud
and say all right I'm ready to get eaten
by this monster there is no monster and
then that aperture expands it opens
because now you've actually gone
processed Without Even Trying by going
and looking and seeing there is nothing
to be afraid of that opens the aperture
automatically it's beautiful I love that
I love that metaphor yeah that's awesome
wow well okay thank you so much I've
taken enough of your time and I just
love the way that you're able to
articulate things and thank you for
sharing your story and
um yeah I'm excited for you and
congratulations on a book there's so
much work and especially on such a
generous book that you have made
available if someone really wants to
read it
um but for most people I hope they go to
Amazon and get it or go buy it on audio
because you deserve a little credit for
your experience of sharing it and
helping and thank you so much for the
opportunity and thank you for the work
you're doing I think it's it's fantastic
it's excellent people who are more known
in the mainstream can say you know what
this actually is happening because it is
real it's not just woo-woo stuff so
thank you very much for your service and
making it available to people and the
way that you serve thanks for bringing
that straw back down and being a straw
being a you know yeah well obviously I
signed up for something to do with this
stuff so I have always actually felt
like my career was what it was but that
it was actually just a way to build a
platform for this because this feels
more important in a way yeah
so thank you well thank you so much have
a wonderful day thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today I hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the Subscribe
button